it seems like chat GPT is everywhere
right now this is the new large language
model from openai that can produce human
sounding text in response to
conversational questions and prompts the
results are in some cases shocking with
the tool being used to write everything
from essays to short stories to job
applications whole Industries are
quaking in their boots as copywriters
lawyers journalists editors and even
programmers question their future I
asked chatgpt to write me a poem about a
caterpillar and a mouse that both loved
gaming I thought that would be
sufficiently random and therefore a bit
of a challenge and this is what it came
up with
a caterpillar and a mouse both love
gaming in their house they play for
hours on end chasing quests foes and
friends the mouse clicks with Nimble
Paws while the caterpillar moves with
slow crawls yet together they make a
great team with strategy and skill they
reign supreme their screens are glow
with Vivid light as they game well into
the night for these two unlikely friends
gaming is where their bond never ends I
mean come on that's pretty incredible
the danger is more real for copywriters
that research basic information and
churn out content for search
optimization in other words my old job
this type of content is easily
replaceable less replaceable is content
that requires human thought and
creativity I asked to chat GPT to write
a video script in the style of the
bioneer it was a good attempt but it
also lacked any of the unique and
original ideas I would have brought to
the table myself of course it did all
Chachi PT can do is churn out new
combinations of words already available
online albeit tetrabytes worth of data
it can't identify novel connections or
give hot takes it doesn't have opinions
and it signed off the video by saying
thanks for watching and see you in the
next video I say thanks for watching and
bye for now it's an attempt at mimicking
my Humanity but it's just slightly off
slightly uncanny so there's never been a
better time to be a digital polymath
that's how we survive and thrive in this
new AI era meanwhile chat GPT becomes an
incredible Force multiplier
a tool that can level the playing field
even further so that individuals can
create incredible things in no time for
a more in-depth explanation of the huge
potential offered by these new AIS check
out the link to my recent blog post in
the description down below or check out
the animation playing on the screen
right now I asked to chat GPT to write
me c-sharp code for Unity yes it can
program two that would make a sphere as
a prefab and then spawn countless more
while making them clamor towards a
Central Mass in an organic and erratic
manner it kinda hit it out the park
to be clear this is something I could
have done myself but which would have
taken me hours of effort for a two
minute clip and it's also built a
version of Conway's gain of life for me
a fully playable version of breakout and
the audio visualizer I've been using in
this video
okay so being the bioneer obviously I
wanted to see how this thing could do
for training I know a lot of people are
already using chat GPT to write
themselves training programs but how
good quality are they to start with
there we're gonna look at a functional
training routine how does chat gbt
handle writing a training program does
it understand functional Training
Concepts I'm going to review the program
and we'll see just how good it is at
doing this now a lot of this is about
getting the prompt right in the first
place so we need to ask it the right
questions
but first I'd like to talk about another
way that you can improve yourself using
a digital tool and that's using today's
sponsor Babel so Babel is one of the top
language learning apps in the world that
makes it extremely easy to learn through
short bite-sized lessons that emulate
real life conversation I've been trying
to learn polish for a while that being
because I have polish Roots but I also
have German Roots this is another thing
I've been looking into using the Bible I
actually knew more German growing up
because I had more German relatives we
used to visit Germany and I learned a
bit of German at school it's been great
revisiting it just in fits and starts
using the Babel app and relearning some
of the old Expressions That I Used to
Know
the definition
[Music]
for me the great thing about Babel is
how it lets you learn in small
bite-sized chunks wherever you are in an
app that's convenient and in your pocket
I love the lessons are designed by real
teachers and I love the way it's based
around real life conversation if you
want to try Bible for yourself then use
the link in description down below or
scan the QR code and you'll get 60 off
of your subscription
can you please write me a functional
training program
something to be completed
three times a week that will contribute
to overall functional performance and
health
this should be
um actually using minimal equipment and
suitable for
beginners to intermediate
warm up start with five to ten minutes
of low intensity cardio such as walking
or light jogging to get your heart rate
up and warm up your muscles follow this
with some dynamic stretches for the
major muscle groups such as leg swings
arm circles and walking lunges then
we've got some body weight squats three
sets of 10 to 12 reps push-ups three
sets of 10 to 12 reps dumbbell deadlifts
three sets of 10 to 12 reps dumbbell
rows three sets of 10 to 12 reps and
planks three sets of 30 to 60 seconds
then we're going to finish with 10-15
minutes of high intensity interval
trading or steady state cardio but in
many ways it's missing the mark for
starters it didn't ask me anything about
myself this isn't a personalized
training program at all all it's doing
is giving me a generic list of exercises
I can form what if I can't do 10 to 12
reps of push-ups at the same time it
really doesn't handle every aspect of
human performance I think it really
missed the mark on that one I mean it's
good that we've got a hip hinge but
there's no rotation as I'm always
talking about here there's no single
legged movements there's no vertical
pulling there's no vertical pushing
there's pretty much nothing really there
for your shoulders I would certainly say
that that doesn't hit every aspect of
performance so yeah not so hot on
functional training at the moment but
let's see if we can refine it a little
bit by giving it some cues this doesn't
really do anything for vertical or
vertical pushing nor is there any
rotational Challenge and you please
amend
I mean most people aren't going to know
to do this so already it's kind of
failed at its task
it's giving me goblet squats now which
doesn't really solve the problem that's
random
we've got the same push-ups now I've got
dumbbell Romanian deadlifts let's make
some changes
pull-ups or inverted rows I like the
inverted rows but I really think it
should be pull ups and inverted rows
so again it's still you know really
missing the mark but I think we're
missing the Mark here of what Chachi PT
is really useful for why it's exciting
because you know I could ask any coach
to write me a program I can find them
online if we ask it to do something to
Source something slightly more unusual
more out there maybe we can find
something exciting from its tetrabytes
of information and prompt it to be a
little bit more creative with it because
we've seen in that poem that it can be
creative so yeah I'm gonna ask it to
train me like Batman
thanks chap GPT great try
now can you please write me a training
program that would
turn a normal person into Batman
a hypothetical routine to create a peak
human
this can use more equipment
more out there training methods and we
can train many more times per week if
necessary
please do make it possible to accomplish
however
thanks
had to do this twice actually the first
time it was really fixated on those
three days a week and it tried to cram
everything into three days when I
specifically said I didn't need to so it
was really fixated on that one prompt
the second one was a bit more
interesting started with a strength
training day barbell back squats five
sets of five reps deadlift five sets of
five reps power cleans five sets of
three reps I like this it's getting more
explosive and that's gonna build power
single arm dumbbell press three sets of
eight reps per arm single legroom mini
deadlifts that's a very functional
exercise I have talked about it in the
past in a video barbell AB roll outs
awesome exercise
pull ups five sets of as many reps as
possible so to failure and kettlebell
swings these sets of 20 reps kettlebell
swings being fantastic for all-round
performance I like that they've gone at
the end here as well but then it gets
cut off when it gets the agility and
Mobility training just halfway through
and that's an issue with Chachi petite
that you don't hear about all that much
it can only give you a response up to a
certain length and before it runs out of
characters or that's what it seems like
I ran into this problem with programming
a lot I keep having to ask it to
continue from a set point so that's what
I've done here you cut off again please
continue from the agility and Mobility
routine it says apologies for that
here's the rest of the program so the
agility and Mobility training includes
cone drills three sets of six drills box
jumps three sets of 10 reps ladder
drills three sets of six drills medicine
ball throws three sets of 10 reps foam
rolling 10 to 15 minutes Hugo or Pilates
one to two times per week then we get
endurance training running cycling
swimming hiking and Rowing so the
endurance training I don't think you're
specifically meant to do that in one
workout as we'll see in the mental
trailing in a moment but doesn't make
that super clear anything I would say
that is if you're going to include all
this stuff we could have put something
more interested in here like rock
climbing perhaps see I think it's
lacking once again real insight or
intriguing ideas that could help take
our performance beyond the average it's
still pulling from largely generic
information I guess the problem is it's
looking at the average advice rather
than you know going into the the Deep
cuts the forums that are hard to find
and finding training advice from there
it probably has that information in its
training data it just doesn't know that
that's what I'm really looking for
mental training now this I really like
it's actually Incorporated mental
training so it has understood the
context it understands who Batman is and
that he would need mental training for
Peak all-round Performance something I
talk about on the Channel all the time
the mental training it gives us 10 to 15
minutes of meditation a day one to two
times per day martial arts interesting
to put that in mental training is as
well but it's also you know conditioning
strength training Mobility everything
else tactical training one to two times
per week and a hair there it says
incorporate tactical trading such as
obstacle courses tactical shooting
Batman doesn't use guns but uses a
grappling hook we'll let them off there
interesting they did obstacle course I'd
definitely approve of that and cognitive
training it says incorporate cognitive
training such as puzzle solving or
memory exercises to improve cognitive
function and mental agility I really
approve of this but it's a bit vague so
I'll ask it to elaborate slightly and
give me examples of the kind of
cognitive training and that's where it
kind of LED itself down again gave me
Sudoku crosswords memory games brain
training apps jigsaw puzzles Rubik's
Cubes cryptography strategy games
mindfulness exercises the cryptography
Great Brain Training apps a little bit
vague doesn't actually give me any
examples it does say you can use things
such as Lumosity Elevate and brain HQ
and without meaning to do a full review
they're pretty basic
um I was hoping for something like dual
and back training or better yet 3D
object tracking but I did prompt it I
said we're talking about Batman here
remember Sudoku really and it says
you're right I apologize for my
oversight if we're talking about
training to become like Batman we need
to focus on cognitive exercises that'll
be more suitable for his level of
intelligence and skills here are some
alternative cognitive training exercises
that may be more suitable code breaking
Tactical decision making stealth and
observation training martial arts
techniques mindfulness meditation
some cool examples there but again it's
still quite vague like stealth and
observation training it says Batman
relies heavily on his stealth and
observation skills to gather Intel and
remain undetective this exercise
involves practicing stealth techniques
and honing observation skills to spot
details others might miss sounds cool
but it hasn't actually given us an
exercise we can engage in or let alone
something we could practice at home on
our own but that is again we could ask
attack GPT to expand and he could go
deeper and deeper and hopefully you know
tease out some useful and interesting
information chat GPT is as useful as the
person using it
could you please ask me relevant
questions about my performance and then
use that information to tailor this
program to my current level
so the takeaway message from all this is
that chat GPT is a powerful tool that
can be really useful but we mustn't get
too carried away because it's certainly
not perfect it could be a starting point
for someone going very cautiously but I
really wouldn't recommend it really in
terms of a functional training program
and if you want to become Batman then it
came close it had some ideas in the
right direction but yeah you definitely
need that original knowledge and this is
what I'm talking about it's a force
multiplier it takes your creativity of
knowledge and helps you to do more with
it helps to see different ideas prompts
you maybe just the research I could ask
you to pull out studies for me if I
wanted to or recommend the most
important and Powerful exercises these
are all things I'm going to do you know
it's really interesting but it's not a
complete tool it doesn't replace a coach
doesn't replace human common sense
so what do you think guys is AI poised
to replace coaches do you approve of the
programs it provided as always thanks a
ton for watching
and see you in the next video
foreign